MARCH FIFTH ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE HEARING
WE HAVE THREE BILLS TO CONSIDER
TODAY I DO BELIEVE WE HAVE A
QUORUM MADAM SECRETARY WILL CALL
THE ROLL.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER PRESENT
BIGELOW.
BLOOM [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
THE ROOM.
CAN'T CHOW.
DEEP HERE EGGMAN.
FONG GABRIEL.
GARCIA [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE.
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK HERE READ
THIS YEAR.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH ARE ONLY I THINK PRESENTED
BILL TODAY.
MISS BURKE AB ONE FORTY SEVEN
AND ENJOY THE DO PASS AS AMENDED
RECOMMENDATION --
WOULD YOU LIKE TO BEGIN.
MOVE THE BILL.
I HAVE A MOTION --
BUT AFTER QUIRK IN A SECOND BY
MISS CARILLO JUST TO MAKE SURE
THE AMENDMENT WE WERE SEEKING A
STREAM OF THE STATEMENT OF
LEGISLATIVE INTENT REGARDING THE
USE OF GENERAL FUND DOLLARS.
YES SO WE ARE ACCEPTING A MOMENT
TO REMOVE EM ALLOCATION TO
WILDFIRE AND TO POVERTY CORRECT
OKAY.
HI GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT AB ONE FORTY SEVEN
THE WAY FOR IMPLEMENTATION AND
SOFT SMALL BUSINESS RELIEF ACT
OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THIS
BILL ESTABLISHES A COMPREHENSIVE
AND BOUNCE SET OF POST WAY FOR
TAX COLLECTION RULES IT MAKES
SENSE FOR THE CONSUMER.
SMALL BUSINESS AND THIS SO IN
THREE WAYS.
FIRST -- IT
PROVIDES LEAF RELIEF TO SMALL
BUSINESS BY INCREASING THE
ECONOMIC NEXUS THRESHOLD FROM
1-001-000-2500.
THOUSAND AND IT ELIMINATES THE
TWO HUNDRED OR MORE SEPARATE TAP
TRANSACTIONS THRESHOLD ENTIRELY.
THIS PROVISION ALSO HELP THE
DEPARTMENT OF TAX.
AND FEE ADMINISTRATION BY
LIMITING THE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH TRYING TO REGISTER AND
COLLECT FROM TRULY SMALL OUT OF
STATE BUSINESSES WEREN'T
CIRCUMSTANCES.
THE COSTS OF COLLECTION MAY
OUTWEIGH THE REVENUE GENERATED.
SECOND AB ONE FORTY SEVEN
RECOGNIZES THE REALITIES OF
TODAY'S ECONOMIST ECONOMY BY
REQUIRING ONLINE MARKETPLACES TO
COLLECT SALES TAX AND USE TAX ON
BEHALF OF THEIR THIRD PARTY
RETAILERS.
FINALLY AB ONE FOR SUMMER
PROMOTES CLARITY AND SIMPLICITY
FIRE CRYING RETAILERS TO COLLECT
AND REMIT LOCAL DISTRICT TAXES
ONCE THEY SELL OVER FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
ELIMINATING THE BURDENSOME
REQUIREMENTS TRACK SALES IN EACH
DISTRICT.
WITH THAT I WOULD NORMALLY DO
YOU WANNA SAY SOMETHING --
TREASURE MáS CONS BUT I'D.
THE BILL'S SPONSOR BUT SHE'S
STUCK IN TRAFFIC TO OUR HI MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS THIS --
I'M CASEY O'CONNOR I'M THE
TREASURER FIONA MáS LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR SHE IS RUSHING OVER
HERE BUT WE GOT TO GO WITH THE
COMMITTEE SO I'LL JUST SAY THAT.
SHE'S BEEN WORKING ON THIS
ACTIVELY SINCE YOU THAT THE BOY
THAT THERE WAS AN UNEVEN --
PLAYING FIELD FOR BUSINESSES
THAT WERE BROKEN WATER IN STATE
AND BUSINESSES THAT WERE SELLING
EVEN THROUGH MARKETPLACES
AUDITOR'S OR INDEPENDENTLY
ONLINE.
INTO CALIFORNIA WE JUST --
ARE HAPPY AND ARE GRATEFUL FOR
ASSEMBLY WOMAN BURKE AND CENTER
MCGUIRE FOR CAMPING THIS ISSUE.
AND ACCORDING TO A MARCH TWENTY
SEVENTEEN REPORT BY CAPITAL
FORUM CALIFORNIA LOST THE MOST
OF ANY STATE IN FOR GUN SALES
TAXES WITH MISSING SALES TAX
REVENUES OF FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY
ONE MILLION.
DOLLARS FOR TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE
THINK NOW TO BE CLOSE TO A
BILLION DOLLARS AND WE BELIEVE
THAT THE TAX LAWS TO CATCH UP
WITH THE TECHNOLOGY SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE OTHER WITNESSES.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE --
MARKER PRAYER I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE ON LINE MERCHANTS GUILD I
WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY WOMAN
BURKE. FOR OFFERING THIS BILL
TREASURER --
MOP FOR SPONSORING IT AND CENTER
MCGUIRE FOR COULD ALSO AUTHORING
THE BILL.
WE REPRESENT THIRD PARTY SELLERS
WHO SELL THROUGH ONLINE
PLATFORMS --
WE WANT TO ALSO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN --
FOR FOR ANNOUNCING AT THE
ASSEMBLY REVENUE TAX HEARING HER
DESIRE TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS
OF THIRD PARTY SELLERS.
WHO ARE CAUGHT UP IN SOME
PROBLEMS --
WHO ARE BEING ASKED TO PROVIDE
FOR BACK TAXES PENALTIES AND
INTEREST --
THAT SEEMS TO BE CONTRARY TO THE
CALIFORNIA CODE OF REGULATIONS
AND I'LL CONCLUDE.
BY SEN --
QUOTING IT A PERSON WHO HAS
POSSESSION OF PROPERTY OWNED BY
ANOTHER.
AND ALSO THE POWER TO CAUSE
TITLE. TO THAT PROPERTY TO BE
TRANSFERRED TO A THIRD PERSON
WITHOUT ANY FURTHER ACTION ON
THE PART OF ITS OWNER.
AND WHO EXERCISES SUCH POWER IS
A RETAILER WHEN THE PARTY TO
WHOM TITLE IS TRANSFERRED IS A
CONSUMER.
TAX APPLIES TO HIS GROSS
RECEIPTS FOR SUCH A SALE YET --
THESE THIRD PARTY SELLERS ARE
BEING ASKED BY CD TFA THE PATH
TO PUT PAY BACK TAXES.
AND THEY ARE --
IN A CURRENTLY IN MESHED IN
CONFLICT IN THAT AREA SO WE WANT
TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN AND
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO PASS THIS
MEASURE OUT.
RIGHT ADDITIONAL SPEAKERS AND
SUPPORT.
JENNIFER TANNAHILL WITH ERIN
READ MISTER SEATS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ENROLLED AGENTS WE'RE PLEASED
THAT WITH THE WORK THE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN IT'S DONE AND AS FOR YOU
SUPPORT THE BILL.
OKAY THAT WAS A YEAR THEY GETS
TO SAY MORE THAN.
HER NAME THE ORGANIZATION AND
SUPPORT AFTER TWO SPEAKERS SORRY
YOU GOT A FREEBIE [inaudible]
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN NONE --
WHICH ACTS CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
QUESTION EIGHT OH SORRY I'M
SORRY DOCTOR EVER DOES HAVE A
QUESTION.
ON THE FIRST OF ALL CREEK NOW.
IF IT'S VERY POPULAR.
HAVE YOU SHOWN WHAT TO DO ABOUT
THE CLASS ACTION LIABILITY SO
REMOVED.
SO IT IT HAS BEEN REMOVED IT HAS
BEEN YES IT WAS REMOVED.
GREAT THANK YOU.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO WEAR CLOTHES
AND HAVE A AND MOTION --
BUT AFTER QUIRK A SECOND BY MISS
CARILLO AND I GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL THANK YOU MISS BURKE.
I THE SUSPENSE FILE WE JUST HAVE
TO BILLS --
BOTH AUTHORS OF WAY PRESENTATION
SO AB THIRTY TO AN A. B. FORTY
FIVE WILL BOTH BE MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE.
THERE'S ANYBODY HERE WHO WISHES
TO SPEAK ON ANY --
BILL THAT ANY OF THOSE RIGHT NOW.
OF COURSE THISIS TWO MINUTES
FISCAL ONLY [inaudible]
INCOME UP.
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
I'LL BE QUICK.
WHERE OR BEING LOOSE TODAY?
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR GIVE A
PREFERENCE AS TO WHICH BILL.
THIRTY TO FORTY FIVE YOU HAVE
THE IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SUPPORTER POSE.
EITHER OR BOTH IT'S UP TO YOU
GREAT THINGS CORY SOCIAL HERE
AND BUT HAVE A CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION --
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSITION BOTH
BILLS AB --
THIRTY TWO IS NOT AN ISSUE ABOUT
PRIVATE PRISONS FOR US --
BUT FROM A FISCAL PERSPECTIVE
ELIMINATING THE USE OF THAT TOOL
TO ADDRESS PRISON OVERCROWDING.
INCREASES THE LIKELIHOOD THAT
THEY'LL BE INCREASED PRESSURE TO
USE JAIL FACILITIES TO HOUSE
OFFENDER SO THAT'S THE FISCAL
CONCERN THE SHERIFFS HAVE ABOUT.
EIGHTY THIRTY TWO AND THEN I
HAVE A COMMENT ON THE NEXT BILL
IF -- I NAY
BE FORTY FIVE ALSO MAYHAVE THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSITION AGAIN
OUR CONCERN NOT SO MUCH ABOUT
THE MONEY THAT'S BEING RAISED
BUT THE FISCAL IMPACT OF JAILS --
IS THAT TAKING WHEY THIS TOOL
WILL --
FRIVOLOUS REQUESTS FOR MEDICAL
VISITS THERE ARE PLENTY OF
PROTECTIONS IN EXISTING LAW TO
ALLOW FOR MEDICAL ATTENTION IF
NECESSARY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
SEE NO SPEAKERS NO ADDITIONAL
SPEAKERS THAT CONCLUDES OUR
HEARING AND WE ARE ADJOURNED